give us your poor your tired and your
federal money the leaders of three
Sanctuary cities are begging President
Biden to shower them with some cold hard
taxpayer funded cash as they wind their
hearts out over the big bad Texas
governor busting illegals to their
doorsteps we cannot continue to do the
federal government's job the federal
government must take responsibility and
lead on this humanitarian crisis instead
of leaving it for cities and localities
to handle we need the federal government
to lean in and provide more financial
assistance all of our cities have
reached a point where we are either
close to capacity or nearly out of room
we need more Federal support to be able
to manage this amount of inflow uh it
will crush City budgets around the
country as we know we're looking at
about 1060 million of potential costs
going to next year's budget that's
almost 10% of our entire city budget o
you do know the definition of sanctuary
don't you but maybe they are better off
not seeking help from Team Biden that's
because this White House is acting like
a bunch of n poops on the issue
secretaries blinkin and my orcus coming
back from a meeting with Mexico's
president empty-handed with no big
border deal to announce blinkin did come
up with a strange new term for the
crisis irregular migration H and my
orcus thought the meeting was productive
M that's a fun word doesn't apply here
but a border state Democrat doesn't
think productive is cutting it
watch The Border has been ignored
they're listening too much to the
immigration activists the White House
and a lot of members of Congress and the
Senate listen to the immigration
Advocates but who's listening to the
Border communities we're losing
Democrats they feel that the Democratic
party that the president is not doing
enough well clearly that message is not
breaking through to Democrats so the
party is just praying that voters live
under a rock take a look at the
immigration B security it was just 11%
in August look where it's hopped to now
19% so it's closing in on the economy
the most Google searches for migrants by
state look at all these states Phil
they're all blue States Illinois is one
New York is two Massachusetts is three
New Jersey is four Colorado is five what
you mean people actually care about
immigration Jimmy imagine uh first of
all good to see everybody and bear with
me you are the first sober people I've
spoken to this is going to be a doy yeah
your Uncle Jimmy uh wish him luck well
this is essentially what happened Joe
Biden took the border and turned it into
the college bar that doesn't check ID do
you remember that bar in college where
once the word got out you were going to
get in no matter what okay they
incentivized this but the idea that they
went down there with no deal and had the
I guess hutzpah is that a fair word I'm
trying not to say balls on TV where bear
with me I apologize but the idea that
they came back and said that okay it's
it was productive okay this is a Now
problem we just broke a record for
fental poisoning deaths people are dying
infrastructure is overwhelmed in inner
cities the idea that you call be like
was productive okay it's such an insult
and an indifference to the people being
harmed by this and this the only point I
want to make up okay bring up is that
the Democrats and everyone should
remember this when the election rolls
around and they start telling you no no
we're the party of struggling minorities
and inner cities okay they are crushing
struggling minorities in inner cities
right now by overwhelming schools
obviously and infrastructure and
facilities and it is the biggest screw
you to the people they report to care
about the most so if I am a little
hopped up it's not just the tequila
sodas all right but we'll be serving
plenty of those in your white coffee mug
throughout the show I was promised mark
my word um but Jimmy brings up a point
that you sorted discussed yesterday and
that is you know these Mayors are saying
we only have so many resources
so what are they supposed to do if if
they have declared themselves Sanctuary
cities so they put the bright neon open
sign at the at the front door and now
people are going in how do you solve
this well I think that you have to let
City Council meetings like the one that
was shut down in Chicago where the
people wanted to talk about voting to
make Chicago not a sanctuary City
anymore you have to let those go through
and you have to hear what the people say
it doesn't mean that the policy Is AO
automatically going to be overturned but
you can take that information and you
can go to the federal government or you
can go to your Governors and
say the people do not want this anymore
the people got this in the first place
because they did it is working
differently than it used to you just
look at the people who were advocates
for Sanctuary City policies Chief
amongst them Rudy Giuliani right who
obviously in a very different state of
mind and position in his life was
talking about how important it is that
people could come out of the shadows and
work with law enforcement to talk about
what's going on in their communities to
make us safer and understood that the
people who were coming here were here
for a better life to work hard we're
paying taxes into accounts just in case
the government checked on them wanted
their kids to go to school and to pay it
forward as it were that is very
different to what's going on right now
and it is becoming a quality of life
issue and that's the same thing as the
economy and that's what people vote on
and I always say this this does not mean
that a bunch of Democrats are going to
become bunch of Republicans that's not
this but it does mean that you have but
it does mean a bunch of New Yorkers are
going to become a bunch of
Floridians yeah they are going to leave
and go places where maybe they don't
advertise themselves as sanct but but
Charlie are they just trying to get
money from the federal government oh yes
is is that this play or are they really
trying to shift policies in a more
rational Direction well I think uh
primarily they're just trying to get
money because that's what they do but
the the the larger argument is the you
know what happens when ideology meet
meets reality they sit around and they
talk about this stuff in ideological
terms and it all sounds nice and Rosy
and they also s go even further and tell
other people what it is that that uh you
know their policy solutions for problems
that they're not personally facing and
of course you know the border state
Governors border states have been
dealing with this for 20 years and have
been screaming about it saying we need
to do something about it and all of the
sanctuary City people sit around say oh
I've got all the answers this is what
you do you need to make it and then of
course when that happens all hell breaks
loose and it's a catastrophe and now
we're going to have to dig them out of
the ideological hole that they've gotten
themselves into luckily um I think that
you know I I do think that maybe they
don't become permanent Republicans but
they will vote there this is a very
powerful issue that people do vote on
and uh when they look around and they
see things that as you point out that
don't work whether it's the economy or
you know getting on an airplane and
seeing you know the your tax dollars
paying for illegals to fly around the
country it makes people mad because this
issue doesn't it's not necessarily just
an illegal immigration issue it becomes
an education issue it becomes a
sanitation issue it becomes a public
safety issue when you're cutting budgets
for education for example it becomes a
healthare issue when emergency rooms are
completely overrun with people who are
not paying to the system who are using
the system you know the mayor ofo and
the mayor of New York City continue to
ask Joe Biden to do something about this
they're not doing anything if you read
the readout between the state department
and the president of Mexico that was
issued today it's paragraphs and
paragraphs of gobbly G diplomatic
nothingness but the good news is that
they're going to meet again in January a
couple weeks from now to go over how
this issue can be solved we know how
it's solved there was nothing in that
meeting at least publicly they put out
about any kind of Asylum reform any kind
of and Mexico uh policy that can be put
into place that's what's needed here
this actually is not complicated and
these Mayors there are things they can
do they can say we will not shelter you
we will not give you benefits we will
not allow you to use our our facilities
you will not be welcome here but they're
not doing that they're just asking for
more money to manage more people coming
into the country as Charlie said they're
perfectly fine with this happening in
places like Texas and Arizona but don't
want to hold the federal government
accountable that's the issue because
Texas and Arizona they cannot absorb so
because they know that the more they
overrun the system the odds are in their
favor that they'll be able to get into
the country they won't have court dates
for six seven years and it just goes to
all the layers that are broken because
it's not just the cities it is the
federal government it is diplomacy that
has broken down it's immigration it's
Border Protection it's all of it and it
doesn't seem like anyone is really
serious about fixing it and I would
throw Republicans in there too like they
get really mad about about it but we
haven't seen any solutions from either
side when they get both houses of
Congress and the presidency no we've had
gangs of everything we've had gangs of
six we've had gangs of now we gangs
coming across the border I know Jimmy
that's what you wanted me to say stop it
away um and that's completely correct
there's also a kind of memory hole I
find on my side of the aisle about who
Barack Obama was when it came to the
immigration issue he was known as the
deporter in Chief and he increased his
share of the Latino vote there isn't
people aren't waiting to see that the
border is open that everyone in the
world can come in they want a fair
system that doesn't mean that people
shouldn't be able to claim Asylum that
is something that is important and is
fundamental to the United States but
there is there only votes to be lost by
leaving it as it is there are votes to
be gained for Democrats and you see that
this Alliance of the Henry quars of the
world and John fedman and you have Katie
Hobbs saying I'm gonna send the National
Guard listen down to the Border I I knew
something was up when Eric Adams left
the nightclub then we were like wow
right this is out of control Turkish
state or no for him to when you went and
ate a stake Jim that's when you knew
this was serious all right the pro Hamas
crowd are some serious Party Poopers
blocking traffic at two major airports
and scheming to ruin your New Year's Eve
plans don't you dare commies that's next
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else